This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
In English, there are many expressions which use an adjective to compare humans with animals.
For example, you might say she's as busy as a bee.
As hungry as a horse.
But you probably won't hear someone say she's as clever as a chimpanzee.
Which is strange because of all the animals.
It's our close cousins chimpanzees or chimps for short who are most like us.
Just like humans chimps are highly intelligent.
They live in social groups and just like humans these groups have leaders.
Also like humans chimps have a desire for power.
In fact, chimpanzees have their own politics, which is surprisingly similar to human politics,
as we'll be discovering in this programme.
Research shows that the reason chimpanzee behaviour so closely resembles human politics
is because biologically we are almost identical.
Did you know that a chimpe is more like a human than like a gorilla?
So Sam, my quiz question is this.
Biologically, how close are chimpanzees to humans?
Is it a 79% b 89% or c 99%?
Well, near if chimps and humans are almost identical, I'll guess c 99%.
Okay, Sam, we'll find out the correct answer at the end of the programme.
In human societies, of course, not everyone gets to be a political leader.
It's usually the most powerful or ambitious person who becomes president.
In chimpanzee society, this is called the alpha male.
The most successful and powerful male who leads the group.
Professor Franz DeVal is an expert on chimpanzee behaviour.
Here he is on BBC World Service programme, the wife actor,
telling presenter James Tilley about one example of chimped behaviour,
which closely mirrors human politics.
All the males who are over the hill and cannot be alpha male anymore,
they start grooming a certain young male who they think has a future
and they may end up making that young male the alpha male,
with their help, meaning that they are essential to the power of that young male.
But then the power behind the throne, really.
Yeah, these older males, and you see that in human politics all the time,
these older males who have a lot of influence still.
Professor DeVal calls chimps who are too old to be alpha males over the hill,
a phrase describing someone who is old and no longer useful or attractive.
Older chimps try to control younger males in order to maintain their own power and influence.
In other words, they are the power behind the throne,
an expression meaning someone with no official power,
but who secretly controls things in the background.
Another example of chimped politics is when several weaker males gang up and overthrow a stronger alpha male.
By working together weaker chimps can increase their power and the benefits,
like food, which power brings.
According to Simon Hicks, Professor of Political Science at the London School of Economics,
human alliances work in exactly the same way.
Here is Professor Hicks speaking with BBC World Service Programme, the wife actor.
So for example, if you imagine three parties in a parliament, one big one and two small ones,
you might think that naturally the most likely coalition is the big party with either one of
the two small ones, or as in fact a minimum winning coalition prediction would suggest the two
smaller ones should get together if together they can reach more than 50% of the seas,
because they can divide up the spoils between the two of them, whereas if either one of them
formed a coalition with the big party, the big party would dominate and they wouldn't get many of
the spoils for themselves. Professor Hicks recommends that smaller political parties get together,
join together in a group to combine their power.
These smaller parties could form a coalition, a collection of different political groups who unite
for a limited time to form a government. In human politics making coalitions improves your
chances of winning an election. And in chimpanzee politics coalitions are a good way for young male
chimps to defeat the alpha male and divide up the spoils between themselves. Here the word spoils
means the benefits obtained by winning a war or being in a strong position.
For ambitious alpha chimps the spoils might include getting first choice of food and female partners.
Well for human politicians power can bring wealth and fame as well.
And there's something else alpha chimpanzees and human politicians have in common,
they like to show off their softer side by kissing babies.
It looks like chimps and humans share many similar behaviors after all,
which reminds me of your quiz question Neil. Yes in my quiz question I ask Sam how similar we are
to chimps. What did you say Sam? I said that biologically speaking we are C, 99% the same.
Which is the correct answer well done Sam you are as clever as a chimps.
Thanks Neil and you're definitely not over the hill. Let's recap the recovery from today's program
about chimps politics starting with alpha male, the most successful and powerful male in any group.
Over the hill is used to describe someone who is old and no longer useful or attractive.
Someone who is the power behind the throne secretly controls things but has no official power.
Get together means join together as a group. A coalition is one different political groups,
temporarily unite to form a government. And finally the spoils are benefits or
advantages gained by winning a war. And that's all for this program, bye for now. Goodbye.